[Música]
vamos a nuestra revista de prensa con
Marta Moya Marta Buenos días para usted
Hola Ángela Buenos días bien Marta vamos
a abrir esta sección o con una
investigación de que realiza la bbc
aprovechando el Día Mundial del
refugiado una investigación más bien
escabrosa que denuncia que hay migrantes
afganos que están siendo Víctimas de
secuestro y además torturados por
pandillas iraníes en ese camino que
inician para intentar llegar a Europa
Pues sí Ángela una investigación cuanto
menos escalofriante Claro sabemos que
desde la llegada del talibán a
Afganistán otra vez en el año 2021
millones de afganos han intentado salir
del país esta investigación de la bbc
nos acerca escalofriantes historias de
algunas de estas personas que utilizan
la ruta para llegar a suelo europeo
primero van de Afganistán a Irán de Irán
a Turquía y de Turquía ya pasan a suelo
europeo sin embargo muchos de ellos se
quedan atrapados en la frontera entre
Irán y Turquía una ruta que hoy según la
bbc es más peligrosa que nunca la
también ha tenido acceso a vídeos donde
migrantes afganos son torturados por
pandillas iraníes en puntos fronterizos
entre estos dos países la bbc tiene
vídeo registrados en al menos 10 puntos
fronterizos donde los migrantes son
Víctimas de secuestros y luego de
torturas por estas pandillas en unos
primeros vídeos recopilados por este
medio británico las personas están
encadenadas en la cima de una montaña
con candados alrededor de sus cuellos y
uno de ellos dice textualmente quien vea
este vídeo no secuestraron ayer y están
exigiendo 4.000 dólares por cada uno de
nosotros nos golpean día y noche los
secuestradores perpetran estos
secuestros y torturas del lado iraní de
la frontera y después les piden sumas
altísimas a unas personas que ya han
tenido que pagar cantidades muy elevadas
para transitar rutas más o menos seguras
en su salida de Afganistán este
reportaje también cuenta la historia de
amina una joven afgana que intentó
cruzar a suelo Turco entonces estaba
embarazada Las bueno autoridades
fronterizas turcas las devolvieron a
Irán por la noche Y entonces fueron
secuestrados ella y otros miembros de su
familia por Una Pandilla iraní les
pedían una suma altísima de dinero y su
padre tuvo que vender su casa en
Afganistán para que bueno pues fueran
liberados ese esa inseguridad y esa
desprotección para los migrantes que
hacen estos caminos tan peligrosos Marta
vamos a cambiar de tema por otro de
nuestros titulares en los noticieros del
día de hoy después de la desaparición
del submarino que tenía la misión de
explorar los restos del Titanic en una
Ultra lujosa expedición al yacira nos
hace un explainer con los datos más
relevantes de esta historia que se
convirtió en un drama pues se Angela una
expedición bien bizarra Quizá no tanto
como la empresa alemana que patrocina o
bueno proyecta viajes exclusivos para
cruzar la selva del darián pero también
una expedición bien bien bizarra al
decir entonces nos da las claves un poco
de esta expedición Aparentemente fallida
estamos hablando de un submarino operado
por la empresa
oceangate que está radicada en
Washington en Estados Unidos el domingo
cinco personas se suben a este submarino
dirección a explorar los restos del
Titanic que sabemos pues se hundió en el
año 1912 entre ellas como comentábamos
un empresario británico y un Magnate
pakistaní junto a su hijo de 19 años una
expedición millonaria porque cuesta el
pasaje más de 250 mil dólares esto se da
en el mar del Atlántico Norte y se
enmarca en una serie de viajes que ya
había hecho esta empresa a ver las
profundidades del Titanic desde el año
2021 el submarino se sumerge a una
profundidad de 3.900 metros y puede
dotar de oxígeno a sus tripulantes unas
96 horas por lo que estas horas podrían
ser claves para hallar a las personas
que se incursionaron esta expedición
estaría a unos 1500 kilómetros de la
costa más cercana entre Canadá y Estados
Unidos y en su web el Ocean Gate dice
que sus sumergibles están hechos para
soportar las presiones de las
profundidades oceánicas que ya hicieron
más de 50 pruebas en las profundidades
de las Bahamas y que la misión está
basada en hacer una crónica del
deterioro del Titanic y además del
ecosistema submarino que se genera a
partir de esos restos de los naufragios
de los barcos Claro pero ahora nos
estamos enfrentando a un submarino que
está a más de tres mil metros de
profundidad en una zona donde
difícilmente habrá algo de luz es una
búsqueda casi imposible Marta
absolutamente bien y vamos a cerrar con
otra noticia Pero esta vez de New York
Times tal vez tengamos tiempo para una
más que nos reafirma una vez más que las
relaciones entre Moscú y Washington han
sido tensas desde hace mucho tiempo Esto
no es nuevo pero si los detalles que
entrega el medio Así es Ángela titula
hoy Rusia buscó asesinar a un desertor
en Florida esto se enmarcaría en una
operación clandestina que buscaba a
eliminar a un informante de la Cia en
Miami que había sido un alto funcionario
de la inteligencia rusa hacia una década
todo esto pasó entre el año 2010 y el
año 2020 esta persona se llamaría
Alexander y ese día pues un miembro ex
miembro de la inteligencia rusa qué
habría revelado que bueno unas
informaciones que condujeron a una
investigación del FBI en dos en 2010 por
las que se atrapó a 11 espías rusos que
vivían en suburbios de la costa este
estadounidense el gobierno de Putin
consideró todo esto como una traición lo
condenó por Rebeldía primero lo dieron
por desaparecido y luego intentaron
acabar con su vida en el año 2020 una
operación fracasada que sin embargo
condujo Bueno pues a un episodio más de
la extensas relaciones entre Moscú
Washington con la expulsión de
diplomáticos a uno y otro lado y con la
expulsión también de agentes de
inteligencia Ángela muy bien Ahora sí
para el cierre Marta una latinoamericana
en Ecuador el diario El País nos acerca
a uno de los candidatos presidenciales
que está buscando reeditar la fórmula
ukl para ganar las elecciones
anticipadas de agosto veremos si le
sirve o no esta estrategia Pues si
Ángela nos referimos a llanto pic un
tipo que no se considera ni de derechos
ni de izquierdas ni de Centro que quiere
gobernar Ecuador con base textualmente
en un esquema de decisiones apolítico
algo bizarro no gobernar un país
considerándose apolítico estas
tendencias de candidatos independientes
no Así es quiere basar su política y su
Campaña en la seguridad reeditando la
fórmula de nayib buken El Salvador este
tipo tiene 40 años es de Guayaquil que
es una de las regiones y ciudades más
afectadas por la crisis de seguridad que
enfrenta Ecuador en estos momentos
quiere lanzar su campaña bajo el eslogan
Ecuador sin miedo y ya ha empezado a
recorrer el país Pese a que la campaña
no ha empezado con Botas militares en
helicóptero y bajo la banda sonora de
Top Gun es millonario regenta una
empresa de tecnología y seguridad y fue
soldado en la legión extranjera francesa
como francotirador y paracaidista dice
que utilizará la mano dura y que los
políticos en Ecuador les faltan
pantalones Así que pretende salvar a
Ecuador reeditando esa fórmula
buquelista que la hemos visto mucho en
América Latina y que es normal en la
alternancia de esta región Muchísimas
gracias a usted Marta gracias Ángela